[Musique]
le monde est trop grand maman alors à
petit cela concentre toi sur la voie
imagine que c'est une île en plein océan
tu la vois
je la vois non
mon fils était dans le bus
il a vu ce que clark a fait
[Musique]
tu pourras gardée secrète cette face
cachée de toi qu'est ce que j'aurais dû
faire les laisser mourir
non
peut-être
[Musique]
j'ai tellement de questions
d'où à ce que je viens
oh
[Musique]
c'est à toi de décider quel genre
d'homme tu veux être clark
[Musique]
quel que soit cet homme
changera le monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
r penser que si les hommes découvrent
est ma vraie nature
il ne rejetterait
il était persuadé
q le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais bon